In Season 1, Episode 6 of "The Big Bang Theory,"
"The Middle Earth Paradigm," Penny throws
a Halloween party in her apartment.
Leonard shows up as a Hobbit, hoping to show
Penny he can fit into her circle of friends.
But things take a disappointing turn when
Penny's beefy ex-boyfriend Kurt shows up,
decked out in a physique-baring fur loincloth.
And when Leonard manages to insult Kurt's
marginal intelligence, the angered muscleman
hoists Leonard off his hairy Hobbit feet.
As Johnny Galecki says in author Jessica Radloff's
"The Big Bang Theory: The Definitive, Inside
Story of the Epic Hit Series," the scene took
him back to his youth.
He admitted,
"Him picking me up as Leonard really affected
me to the point where I think I cried after
we shot the episode […] it really dug up
some old schoolyard stuff for me.
I had a way into Leonard and really began
to understand him."
So while the scene may have been intense for
the actor, it also opened a window into the
character Galecki would play for over 270
more episodes of "The Big Bang Theory."